[Música]
nasci e cresci no aglomerado morro das
pedras no conjunto santa maria que fica
dentro na em belo horizonte
é preciso entender um pouquinho porque
esse contexto desse território
bh tem aproximadamente 260 vilas e
favelas
estou falando só da capital ali do
miolinho mesmo se for pra grande bh
esse número triplica e com isso também
na desigualdade crime violência e claro
a falta de oportunidades
era um lugar difícil para os jovens
criar mas eu mesmo tendo nascido na
favela
eu sempre quis mudar o mundo sabe eu
tinha um desejo muito grande de fazer
alguma coisa e eu também tinha alguns
desejos pessoais
eu queria onde um favelado tinha ido
antes eu queria conhecer mais do mundo
entender mais como funcionava
na minha época a gente tinha uma coisa
que a gente chamava de lugar de boy
lugar de boy era aquele lugar que você
não podia ir porque não tinha grana que
você não tinha roupa certa era preto e
favelado
enfim eu tenho que conversar com vocês
que no fundo no fundo né
eu sempre quis um lugar de goya porque
eu sempre tive dentro de mim que aquele
lugar que tinham algo mais pessoas
interessantes conhecimentos interessante
que a gente podia adquirir e claro
oportunidades quando né a gente cresce
nasce na favela
essa reflexão é uma coisa que sempre
incomoda gente é algo que quer muito
forte mas se você nasceu num ambiente
privilégios acolhida então você não
consegue entender o que é essa ausência
de oportunidades que a gente tem e eu
quando era mais novo era muito curioso
sabe eu era quase que um antropólogo eu
queria saber onde começava quando
chegava ali o que acontecia
depois que eu chegar ele o que mais né
que sempre que mais o que mais o que
mais eu brinco que se fosse nos dias de
hoje né eu eu tanto queria saber de tudo
o pessoal fala que eu queria ser quase
que o google humana começou de 80 eu
estava mais para uma barra humana sabe
assim eu queria saber disto o edital e
misturar
e afins e uma coisa que muito forte sabe
de todos os rolês de todas as conexões
de estar nesses lugares que trouxe
começou sem muitas reflexões reflexões
dentro de mim principalmente a dos
cofres da minha mãe da minha avó
eu li pequeno é fechando o tempero na
vela que minha mãe fazia para poder
complementar a renda em casa e também
escolas que os meus amigos faziam sabe
entre uma coisa e outra para poder
ganhar dinheiro é brincadeira escola e
afins
e foi esse o meu primeiro contato que eu
posso dizer com vocês com o
empreendedorismo sabe como
empreendedorismo e empoderado como que a
gente poderia fazer várias coisas por
meio do do empreendedorismo mas uma
confissão que eu gosto sempre de fazer
quando converso com as pessoas que mesmo
né como eu falei nascer e crescer e
viver até hoje na favela um cara muito
privilegiado porque eu tivesse a
educação formal
sáb tive algumas oportunidades de acesso
à educação e marketing empreendedorismo
e inovação
mas o que foi mais importante desse
acesso nem foi a questão de realmente
detê lo mas também a questão de como que
nesses conhecimentos novos que adquirir
eu pude ver esses corpos da favela numa
outra perspectiva de como o que a gente
fazia dentro da favela em questão de
potencial criativo inovação
empreendedorismo já estava tão adiantado
e mais importante do que isso como que a
gente poderia muito mais além como que a
gente poderia criar o nosso próprio
ecossistema de inovação empreendedorismo
e dialogar com o ecossistema do asfalto
numa lógica de troca de lugar de poder e
não mais como laboratório de
experiências que as pessoas iam fazer a
coleta de dados desenvolvido um projeto
que nunca mais voltava pra você só
entenderem contexto nasceu tudo isso
belo horizonte tem um ecossistema muito
forte de inovação e empreendedorismo
mas se é que o sistema é muito voltado
para o empreendedorismo de base
tecnológica negócios formais do asfalto
olhar muito assim quem é o público
desses programas de acesso a recursos e
acesso à informação
é uma galera branca privilegiada que
teve muitos acessos e privilégios
é completamente diferente da galera que
vem de onde houve inclusive de mim e
quando a gente começou a refletir sobre
isso né eu e hoje a equipe que a gente
tem na favela é grande parte ainda está
com a gente hoje a gente começou a
entender que cara a gente precisa fazer
alguma coisa a gente precisa entender
como que a gente vai mudar isso um pouco
ea gente começou a entender que a gente
precisava não só instrumental as pessoas
mas também descobri como que a gente ele
exponenciar esse potencial criativo e
empreendedor que tinha da favela início
nasceu o favela é o favela ele hoje é
basicamente uma aceleradora de projetos
e negócios
o totalmente orientada para ajudar a
criar e fomentar esse ecossistema de
empreendedorismo e inovação dentro de
territórios vulneráveis vilas e favelas
e hoje nós já estamos três anos e meio
entre três anos e meio quatro anos já
nesse trabalho e onde que a gente
oferece desde programas de aceleração
que são durante três e quatro meses
antes que as pessoas têm acesso à
educação formal em marketing comunicação
estratégia gestão financeira que é um
dos grandes né calcanhar de aquiles que
a gente tem dentro desses pequenos
negócios e também já oferece diversos
cursos curtos sabe que as pessoas
começam a a repensar também antes até de
entrar num programa de aceleração ao
falo dessa oferta é que a gente faz pra
você que nasceu num contexto de mais
privilégio e consegue ter acesso a essa
educação formal
pode parecer um pouco distante essa
reflexão
mas quando a gente pensa nesses
empreendedores que a gente atende eu
volto um pouco até pra mim porque eu sou
o joão
sou filho de irene cabeleireira geral do
mecânico que conserta a geladeira e da e
neta de dona lilia que foi minha avó que
foi uma matriarca fantástica uma mestre
é uma guia até hoje é que eu brinco que
mesmo tanque presencialmente ela me
acompanha e todos os ensinamentos dela e
quando eu começo a refletir de mim do
acesso que a gente quer oferecer precisa
esses empreendedores a gente começa a
pensar também muito
analógica de que o empreendedor entre da
favela é um ato político
então todo empreendedor que está ali
dentro hoje da favela empreendendo ele
está de alguma forma mudando é um agente
de mudança para poder não só a impactar
né o seu território e seu pequeno
negócio ali mas também tentar inverter
essa lógica da pirâmide sabe inverter um
pouco a mão do dinheiro e mostrar esse
potencial empreendedor e criativo que a
gente tem dentro da favela
mas nesses quatro anos de trabalho na
favela geram muitas coisas interessantes
diversos aprendizados né e eu trouxe
duas histórias hoje que eu queria muito
muito muito compartilhar com vocês de
duas histórias que a gente é assinante
apaixonado não foi difícil escolher
porque tem várias e tudo e uma delas né
de uma personagem super real que é
chamar eliza ela é uma cabeleireira do
morro do papagaio que foi um dos
primeiros programas de aceleração que a
gente rodou em belo horizonte ea jumar e
quando a gente conheceu ela arrumar ela
tem black power linda assim sabe
imponente mesmo ela chega realmente uma
marca pela presença assim era uma coisa
que chamava muito nossa atenção mas
também chamava muita atenção dos
moradores do morro do papagaio todo
mundo que via gilmar a querer saber pois
como é que eu faço para ter um cabelo
como seu eu queria muito saber entender
como que é e tudo se faz também pra mim
e tudo e quando a gente tem um
determinado momento dentro do programa
que a gente sai da fase dada somente da
capacitação e vai para uma fase em que a
gente começa a validade dos
empreendedores é faz uma espécie de
idéia são ali para que eles consigam
continue na modelagem
a gente teve uma reunião com gilmar e
essa reunião foi uma reunião que a gente
tava super empolgado né porque você
imagina elas favelados tinham saído da
favela gente dá acesso à educação
superior nessa vida de tudo né agora
eles vão falar com ela como era
importante é investir naquilo naquele
tipo de negócio
a gente acreditava muito que o salão é
a aproveitando a lógica do empoderamento
estético negro ela abrir um salão afro
dentro da favela era melhor ideia do
mundo
iniciante foi pra reunião com gilmar e
insistindo batendo nessa tecla e jumar
muito muito muito inquieta na cadeira e
de repente o momento as marinas
interrompeu e ela trouxe gente é eu
quero abrir um espaço da noiva
na hora que ela falou isso né gente tipo
mudou na cadeira nexpa da noiva nem acho
que a gente falou assim quase que elas
gostem comercial é a espada no waç pupo
e ela é eu quero muito muito espaço da
noiva ea gente ficou meio assim
e ela já vai falar assim gente sem noção
quantos casamentos têm por ano aqui
dentro da favela
aí a gente metas aquela cara né de
ampulheta do windows é travado sinte co
a gente não sabe é essa e ela foi já
veio com outra segunda pergunta e falou
assim você sabe quantas noites saem da
favela e vão gastar dinheiro com o dia
da noiva fora da favela da zona oeste
não sabe nada disso mesmo
acho que ele estava se recuperando ela
veicula assim olha sou evangélica
você sabe quantos casamentos têm por mês
dentro da igreja evangélica
nessa hora a gente tipo hoje tem que
responder alguma coisa que já tá ficando
muito chato né gente que estava aqui pra
ensinar é que de repente a gente não
está sabendo responder a este
profissional gilmar a gente não sabe não
quantos casamentos tem não
e ela veio falar com a gente assim então
eu quero esse público não só pra mim que
vou oferecer o serviço de espada à noiva
mas para os fotógrafos maquiadores e
para outros profissionais de beleza que
queiram ser parceiro do meu negócio e é
isso que eu quero oferecer pra isso
nessa hora eu confesso para vocês não é
como eu falei eu tiver acesso à educação
superior e marketing
nessa hora dentro de mim sabe eu estava
chorando por dentro pensando da grana
que eu gastei fazendo até pós em
marketing e de repente estava ali uma
área sabe dar uma masterclasse pra mim
assim e eu respirando mas ao mesmo tempo
foi um sentimento muito bom
porque ela já tinha passado por uma
parte da formação era uma partida que a
gente fala muito sobre tendência a gente
fala sobre análise de mercado e tudo e
de repente a gente viu também que como a
forma como a gente escolheu trabalhar a
educação empreendedora voltada para a
inovação ea criatividade que esses
empreendedores estava dando certo e de
repente tinha gilmar mostrando pra gente
que ela acreditava no potencial do
negócio que ela queria fazer que era
totalmente contrário às nossas idéias da
tendência inovadora de tudo que a gente
já tinha visto pelo mundo né
ela estava mostrando pra gente que não
acreditava no negócio dela e que a gente
realmente estivesse disposto a ajudar
ela nisso ela iria muito longe e não é
que ela foi gilmara semana passada ela
veio procurar a gente pra poder contar
que ela está abrindo a segunda unidade
dela né
o a segunda unidade dela vai ficar num
bairro que é do lado do morro do
papagaio porque ela estava tendo um
problema de logística é porque como não
sabe
a questão não é de um pouco de mito e
realidade sobre violência das favelas
impedem as pessoas de entrarem nas
favelas de usar o serviço é diferente em
bh a jumar já tinha um trabalho muito
grande de logística que era da filha
dela às vezes o filho buscar as pessoas
fora da favela para poder levar para ser
atendido no salão e depois levar as
pessoas até na porta da favela então ela
resolveu isso abre uma nova unidade né
a vendedora de impacto net povoado
unidade é que resolveu problema net
abrindo portas resolver os problemas mas
super consciente depois de dois anos e
meio quase três anos a gente a sua super
o momento ela procurou a gente entendeu
que a gente ficou super super super
feliz com isso né isso é uma coisa legal
dentro o modelo que a gente usa na
favela
a gente tem até uma metodologia game
ficada que permite permite a gente tanto
a parte de capacitação quanto à parte
também da modelagem dos negócios com os
empreendedores mas ela não é rígida um
fio condutor
ela nos permite adaptar às necessidades
dos empreendedores a forma como eles
querem trabalhar esses negócios está
disposto a ouvir realmente esse
posicionamento deles e ajudá los da
forma que eles querem ser ajudados
também então isso pra gente é é super
fantástico o que impacta também no
modelo de negócio da favela que o favela
mesmo com esse nome e não é só
favelas falei com vocês de duas
histórias né a segunda história é uma
história que para a gente ela é muito
legal porque foi um momento de muita
inovação no nosso modelo que é a mulher
me guilherme é um jovem do movimento sem
terra que ele descobriu o nosso edital
através de uma postagem no facebook e
nos procurou
o guilherme quando ele nos procurou ele
falou que a gente cara eu quero muito
abrir um negócio focado em agroecologia
pra que irá capacitar jovens do
movimento sem terra que também estão
dentro dos assentamentos como eu e que
eles possam não somente produzir
agroecologia para poder vender o entorno
mesmo na capital em bh mas também que
eles também possam prestar um serviço de
assessoria técnica para quem quer montar
selar uma parede uma horta vertical em
casa um restaurante que montar um jardim
com comestível e tudo pra gente foi dois
grandes desafios primeiro a gente tava
falando do assentamento sem terra que
não era nosso território de origem
a gente estava falando sobre
agroecologia que era uma coisa que tava
super tendência a gente nunca tinha
trabalhado e também foi outro caso que
deu muito certo pra gente
o guilherme na próxima semana ele está
entre o reino unido com esse modelo que
a gente ajudou a criar agora se que a
empresa dele ele tem de receber um
prêmio no reino unido de 10 mil libras é
que ele participou de um concurso então
assim pra gente a gente vê um jovem do
movimento sem terra que chegou para a
gente todo mild com uma ideia muito
pequena ainda que ele queria fazer
de repente esse jovem cruzando o oceano
para poder no reino unido então assim a
gente sempre brinca aqui mesmo jeito que
o pessoal do cenário estátua está atrás
dos unicórnios né a guilherme a nossa
mula sem cabeça né porque a gente gosta
de mitologia nacional mesmo e cara e
isso tudo né pra gente é o que a gente
chama hoje de empreendedorismo de base
foi velada é que esse empreendedorismo
que a galera fazem da favela se virando
com muito pouco fazendo muito é criando
impacto fantástico não só para eles mas
seus núcleos familiares e para as
comunidades que estão anthony ea gente
brinca a gente tem uma de criou uma
equação matemática que virou quase um
mantra para o trabalho que a gente faz
na favela além de converter o
empreendedorismo de base favelada em uma
equação matemática
e a gente fala muito hoje é que é uma
coisa que a gente acredita que está
ajudando a criar de alguma forma vai ser
um legado para as novas gerações que
estão crescendo a favela em territórios
vulneráveis
a gente brinca aqui o nosso da favela é
igual ou maior a 10 deles do asfalto
sabe que tiveram acesso a oportunidades
de acesso à educação superior acesso a
recursos que a gente repete muito esse
mantra pra gente sabe que o nosso é
igual ou maior a 10 deles do asfalto
repete assim umas três vezes antes de
cada reunião assim pra dar aquela
energizada mesmo e manter a gente filme
sabe por que eu acho que acreditar no
potencial criativo e inovador que a
favela tem empreendedor é também um ato
político também pra gente né
eu gostaria de deixar para vocês uma
certeza que o empreendedorismo de base
favelado deste criou pra gente é a nossa
caminhada da favela que é o seguinte a
próxima inovação disruptiva ela será
velada com certeza
obrigado
[Aplausos]